Vous connaissez,
le MIRACLE
MORNING ?
C’est une mode née aux États-Unis
au début des années 2010.
Et l’idée de cette mode,
c’est qu’il faut se lever TRÈS TÔT
— à cinq heures du matin,
par exemple —
parce que se lever très tôt
permettrait de faire plus de choses,
d’être plus productif,
de se sentir mieux
— en somme,
d’être plus heureux.
Eh bien méfiez-vous,
parce que Descartes
EN EST MORT
du MIRACLE MORNING !!
En 1649,
la reine de Suède invite Descartes à Stockholm
pour qu’il devienne son précepteur.
Elle a lu ses livres,
et maintenant elle veut
qu’il devienne son prof
particulier de philo.
Lui,
il se dit qu’il va avoir la belle vie,
en étant le prof de la reine
— mais voilà,
elle le fait venir tous les matins
DE CINQ HEURES
à six heures
dans sa bibliothèque.
Et cinq heures,
c’est le début du cours !
Donc Descartes doit se lever
encore plus tôt !
C’est si difficile pour lui
qu’il tombe malade
au bout de seulement quelques mois.
Le médecin envoyé par la reine
veut lui appliquer
le remède universel de l’époque,
une saignée
— mais Descartes,
qui était probablement meilleur médecin
que ce médecin lui-même,
Descartes refuse la saignée.
Puis il meurt,
à seulement cinquante-trois ans,
en Suède,
alors qu’il voulait
finir sa vie dans sa patrie natale,
la France.
Mais cette fin tragique n’est QU’UNE
des anecdotes surprenantes
de la vie de Descartes
— une vie exceptionnelle,
et exceptionnellement intéressante.
En lisant ce livre,
la « Vie de Monsieur Descartes »
d’Adrien Baillet,
j’ai eu l’impression d’être
dans un roman.
Comme j’avais lu les livres de philo
de Descartes,
comme le contenu de ces livres
est théorique et abstrait,
et puis comme je savais
que Descartes était un mathématicien,
eh bien j’imaginais
qu’il n’avait pas eu une vie trépidante,
je me disais qu’il avait dû
passer la plupart de son temps à Paris,
à lire,
à écrire,
et à résoudre des problèmes
de maths.
Eh bien j’avais faux
sur toute la ligne !
Le génie français du dix-septième siècle
a mené une vie passionnante,
et surtout très enrichissante,
dans le sens
où elle nous fait comprendre
beaucoup de choses
— sur la société de l’époque
et sur le progrès du savoir,
mais aussi sur la société
et sur l’homme en général.
Je vais partager avec vous
dix anecdotes étonnantes
et révélatrices
sur la vie de Descartes.
Vous allez voir
que les dernières sont
croustillantes.
On imagine souvent
que si l’esprit est développé,
alors le corps doit être faible.
On se dit qu’un philosophe,
c’est un rat de bibliothèque,
un intellectuel qui a oublié
qu’il avait un corps,
et qui s’en souvient
quand il doit porter des tomes de 500 pages,
ou monter des escaliers.
Alors,
ce n’est pas toujours vrai
— Socrate et Platon
étaient des hommes forts,
par exemple —
mais pour Descartes,
le préjugé est vérifié.
Descartes EST NÉ
malade.
Quelques jours après sa naissance
le 31 mars 1596,
sa mère meurt
à cause d’un truc aux poumons,
et les médecins pensent
que le nouveau-né la rejoindra
sous peu.
Descartes fera mentir les médecins
puisqu’il vivra quand même
cinquante-quatre ans,
mais il sera faible
physiquement toute sa vie.
Il gardera une faiblesse pulmonaire ;
il aura un corps fin,
c’est-à-dire avec une musculature
très limitée ;
et il gardera aussi toute sa vie
un teint qui ne respire pas la santé,
un teint pâle
que certaines personnes qui le fréquentent
qualifient même d’« olivâtre »
— bref,
c’est pas le président Kennedy.
Est-ce que Descartes
suit un traitement particulier,
d’abord pour survivre,
et puis pour vivre
avec sa faiblesse congénitale ?
Eh bien tout d’abord
il a eu la chance,
dans les premières années de sa vie,
d’être pris en charge par une super nourrice,
qui lui a donné beaucoup de soins
et beaucoup d’amour
— et il lui en sera
tellement reconnaissant que,
dès qu’il commencera à gagner sa vie,
il fera une pension viagère à cette nourrice,